[Music]
an Oregon woman is telling her amazing
story of surviving for seven days after
plunging over a cliff in central
California 23 year old Angela Hernandez
suffered injuries including a brain
hemorrhage and fractured ribs in a
violent crash on July 6th she says she
says she owes her life to two hikers who
saw her car and found her a mile down
the beach in Big Sur
Mireya Villarreal shows us what led to
this remarkable rescue we saw a bumper
first and we were like oh there's a
bumper that's weird and then came around
another Bend and saw the car this is the
car Chelsea and Chad Moore stumbled upon
when they were hiking along the beach in
Big Sur Friday we had no idea someone
was missing we had no idea a car drove
off a cliff until right then in a
Facebook post Sunday
Angela Hernandez says seven days earlier
she swerved to avoid hitting an animal
and plunged to the bottom of a rocky 250
foot cliff the only thing I remember
after that was waking up I could feel
water rising over my knees eventually I
was able to break out of my car and jump
into the ocean I swam to shore and fell
asleep she says the next few days were a
blur she wandered the beach yelling in
vain for help
she says she then found a 10 inch hose
in her car's wreckage she would lay
under the rocks and let water drip off
the rocks into the hose that's the only
way she like drank water the hikers
found her purely by chance about a mile
south of the crash site we turned around
and Angela's right there in the rocks
just look like hell Angela writes when I
sat up I saw a woman walking across the
shore I thought she was a dream photos
captured rescuers attending to Hernandez
and hoisting her to safety
she says doctors told her she had a
brain hemorrhage the crash had also
caused me to fracture four ribs break
and fractured both collarbones and have
a lung collapse over the weekend Angela
reconnected with Chelsea on Instagram
I'll be thankful for you and your
husband every single day for the rest of
my life no one could survive that look
down that cliff at the car there's no
way anyone survived that but Angela did
for CBS this morning media via Los
Angeles
can't tell me miracles don't happen with
watering they're out for her yes yes
more things to do in Angela's life
that's for sure